views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
tonight on politics now attack ads and
pac money we dig into nevada's race for
governor
i think what we have to do is be
practical
senator jackie rosen talks to us about
abortion bills and bringing a new small
arms range to nevada
everyone is being asked to make
sacrifices so that if we can get our
water use down
shrinking pools clark county's latest
effort to save water and when it takes
effect
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler and we
start with the past june's primary
election it's still unsettled business
for republican gubernatorial candidate
joey gilbert this week he filed a
lawsuit challenging the results clark
county sheriff joe lombardo beat gilbert
by about 26 thousand votes a statewide
recount paid for by gilbert did not
change the outcome
gilbert's lawsuit claims there were
errors though in how the votes were
counted he also claims he won by a wide
margin however his campaign has not
offered any proof to back up its claims
republican senate candidate adam laxalt
meanwhile has hired a new communications
director courtney holland this is the
first campaign holland has worked on and
she has a big online following holland
was an organizer of protests outside the
clark county election headquarters which
claimed the 2020 election was stolen she
was also at the capitol on june january
6 last year at the rally for former
president donald trump holland did not
go inside the capitol and she hasn't
been charged with anything
nevada senator jackie rosen recently
announced a new training range for the
nevada national army national guard this
week i spoke with her about that and
abortion-related bills as well as mental
health
let's first of all start talking with a
measure that has been introduced with
regards to hawthorne and training i know
it's been an effort to try and not only
help uh military personnel a find places
to live and that sort of aspect of life
but just the idea of keeping the
training and what hawthorne means to
nevada talk about this measuring where
things stand
well i can tell you i'm so excited about
the new a small arms training range it's
going to be built in hawthorne army
depot and let me tell you why i meet
with the national guard all the time for
those folks who are listening who don't
know national car they help us with the
wildfires every single season of course
block people have seen them during covid
they help with our coleman response up
and down the state but they also get
deployed right now we have nevada
national guard in kuwait and throughout
europe and so it's important that they
maintain their proficiencies and we
didn't have a training range for them to
do that they had to travel out of state
it was costing the army um
five to six hundred thousand dollars a
year and they didn't have anything on
the books to build something in nevada
until about 2030. one area where there
hasn't been a whole lot of agreement is
the issue of abortion on capitol hill uh
the house has done what it is tried to
do i know you and the senate and senator
cortez masto have worked with other
democrats as well to try and uh
overcome some what the removal of roe v
wade and the overturning has done
nevada being where it is close to
arizona and utah you're expecting a lot
of women to be coming here to get that
care
what kind of discussions where do things
stand to try and get something done from
your point of view
on the senate floor
well i can tell you that republicans
have
selfishly blocked catherine cortez
cortez-masto's bill to allow women to
travel free of fear to seek the medical
care that they may need
they blocked this bill i'm a co-sponsor
of that bill with senator cortez masto
women across this country should be able
to travel freely to seek medical care or
honestly for any other reason and so the
republicans they want to implement a
nationwide abortion ban they want to
restrict women's right to travel
i would say not just for abortion care
if they're going to check every woman
who's traveling i think that we should
all have a problem with that there's
another bill to try and potentially
expand the supreme court uh it's a
conservative court as you know um
speaking of roe v wade is there a
concern on your end if this actually
does go through it you know this is a
lot of democrats want this
after the midterms if all of a sudden
the senate isn't in control of the
republicans the house gets flipped
your
democrats might end up in more of a
on the back than they were before
well i can tell you that i don't support
that we don't have the votes for that
right now and i think what we have to do
is be practical women are suffering
right now and i can point to story after
story after story of women seeking uh
health care for abyss care jacktopic
pregnancy there's cases of rape or
incest people are going to the hospital
critical care needs a really important
and
more broadly women should have the
choice to make their own reproductive
health care decisions and so
what we have to do is put our head down
be practical see what we can get past
now and again i'm just going to say we
need to protect and expand our
democratic pro-choice majority at all
levels of government final question uh
it's an issue that a lot of people have
been pushing for more access to to
mental health care the new number 988 is
now in effect
what are the benefits and what kind of a
level what kind of work has been done at
the federal level
from the senate's point of view to get
this done
well i can tell you i'm so proud to see
the 988 i'm going to repeat that
988 that number to come
to fruition we subsidized that with
funds from the american rescue plan i
was glad to help bring forward that
funding we used to have a 10 digit
number hard to remember and if someone's
in crisis
and if anyone out there is listening to
me and you're in crisis now you can dial
988 you're going to get connected as
someone in their community someone will
listen you can get the support and help
you need because we want to help save
your life or the life of someone that
you love who you know is in distress
we have the full interview with senator
rosen on 8 news now dot com
republican gubernatorial candidate and
sheriff joe lombardo in clark county he
calls the latest attack ad against him
anti-police it features the family of a
metro police officer who died from covet
19.
joe lombardo refused to give my husband
the line of duty honors he deserves joe
lombardo didn't even come to the funeral
so this ad that you're looking at right
here the spot was paid for by a stronger
nevada a pack backed by the democratic
governors association the metro officer
you're seeing on the screen there died
from covet 19. metro ruled though it did
not count as an in line of duty death so
benefits were not extended to families
lombardo's campaign says anytime metro
loses an officer it is devastating
however the campaign adds changing the
decision from metro's board would be
committing fraud
a pro-lombardo pack meanwhile is getting
a lot of money from las vegas
businessman robert bigelow he
contributed three and a half million
dollars to a better nevada with the goal
of defeating governor sisilak bigelow
had to lay off workers at his aerospace
facility in north las vegas during the
coronavirus shutdowns
more steps are being taken to limit
water being used from lake mead and this
week clark county commissioners approved
a las vegas valley water district plan
limiting the size of new swimming pools
jeremy j ford explains the changes
across the valley with summer
temperatures averaging well into the
triple digits property owners may be
looking to get a pool to cool off but
now they may have to rethink the size
this feels like it's one of the things
we have to do the las vegas valley water
district is concerned about water
conservation that 600 square foot size
limit is expected to save 3.2 million
gallons of water every year john
insminger oversees the water district
and the southern nevada water authority
no one industry is being singled out
everyone is being asked to make
sacrifices so that if we can get our
water use down to that 86 gallons per
capita right now the water district
argues many pools in the valley exceed 3
000 square feet and are just for looks
kevin kraft of aussie craft pools makes
his money building luxury pools he tells
me there's a better solution to the
problem which includes a conservation
fee that could be paid if someone wanted
to go over that they would pay a
substantial conservation fee because as
it stands he's already lost the client
we already know of 150 million dollar
project that was scrapped from today's
meeting
it's a rather large contract that's
that's no longer on our books jeremy j
ford live local now
now this all comes as we see more
shocking images like this of lake mead
and the colorado river valley these are
satellite pictures from nasa and you can
see here how much part of the lake has
shrunk in the last 20 years and then
just in the last two years this is the
overton arm as you can see here and this
is from back in 2000 this is last year
and this is this year you can just see
how much less water there is now the
water district is also recommending a
pool cover to cut down on evaporation
and wasted water for those backyard
pools you might have the 600 square foot
limit mentioned in jeremy j ford's story
starts september 1st
station casinos plans to demolish three
of its oldest properties including two
in north las vegas one of the women
running for north las vegas mayo right
now though has an alternative plan for
their site's future
let's consider instead of tearing these
properties down
retrofitting them number one for women
veterans and everything that they need
we've never done that
never done that there have been a lot of
facilities that have been erected for
men but we've never done anything for
women
state senator pat spearman is a veteran
as well she wants texas station as you
heard to be donated to support women in
the military spearman adds the fiesta
right next to texas station could be
used as a skilled training center to
help those who are losing their jobs to
technology north las vegas city
councilwoman pamela goins-brown is
running against spearman for the mayoral
seat she says it's too early to comment
on the topic of what's next for those
two sites in north las vegas
next on politics now changing the way we
vote
what you're going to be able to do is be
strategic
up next a new ballot initiative to
create open primaries and used rank
choice voting in our elections
plus republicans take a trip to the
border the record numbers of people
trying to cross into the
two three three three three
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
a ballot initiative in front of voters
in november would change how our
elections are run in nevada it would
create an open primary and ranked choice
voting so how does that work here's a
quick explainer
first it creates an open primary meaning
you can vote for anyone on the ticket
right now you can only vote for
republicans if you're republican or
democrats if you're a democrat
the top five would then go on to the
general election in the general election
you would rank them one through five if
someone gets more than 50 percent in the
general election they win if no one gets
50 percent it goes to an instant runoff
the candidate with the fewest votes gets
eliminated their second choice gets
their votes and that continues until
someone has 50 percent
senator sandra cosgrove from better vote
nevada sat down with me to explain why
she and the group votes better votes
nevada thinks this initiative is
necessary
one of the challenges i think that some
have suggested with elections and one of
the reasons nevada democrats went to the
primary instead of the caucus for
example
confusion and just trying to make it
easier for voters to choose who they
want
would you say your
what you're describing makes it easier
i think so because we're giving us a
streamlined ballot you're not having to
worry how my register vote you're just
registered to vote we're going to treat
you the same way as every other
registered voter one ballot and then
we're allowing you to be strategic in
the general election not the political
parties
but technically you only have to pick
one you can say one
what is the um
what is the challenge that you've found
with the better votes nevada
organization and the initiative here to
get this through just finally got
through the state supreme court now so
what is next
how soon might this actually
be take effect
so we had to turn in 141 000 signatures
because with the ballot initiative you
have to go out and talk to nevadans
because that's what initiative's
supposed to do and then if they say that
sounds good to me they sign we turned in
266 000 signatures so when we were
talking to people and gave them the
explanation i just gave you they said
let me sign that so we know we already
have a lot of support um the problem is
is that the democratic party sued us in
court because they didn't want to change
things and political parties like the
status quo and so that's not surprising
to us the nevada supreme court ruled in
our favor
now what we need to do is do exactly
what i'm doing right now is get the word
out we prevailed we had enough
signatures you know we're going to be on
the ballot in november we need people to
vote yes
is there a benefit to going i'm not
saying it's exactly the same i
acknowledge that right but just having
more people involved in the electoral
process for longer beyond the price yes
yes we want and our turnout for this
primary in clark county was 23 percent
that's not consensus we want more people
being engaged so we're we're looking at
again different countries that use this
process alaska is using it right now
maine has been using it they do have
more people showing up because now my
candidate made it through because what
we we see is that if your candidate
doesn't make it through the primary
you're like well i didn't like those two
what do i care now if your candidate
made it through you're more likely to be
engaged and candidates are more likely
to say all right i was number five i'm
probably not going to win i know you're
number one
i have voters that really like me if you
would maybe take one of my ideas i could
tell my voters to make you their number
two but isn't the whole idea of the
primary to
sort of
sort that out so that at the general
election you have you can at the end of
the day find consensus versus keeping a
whole bunch of candidates strung along
through until the general election
so a lot of people will tell you the
purpose of a primary is to pick the
nominees for the political parties that
is not true
if you again the non-partisan races
if somebody gets fifty percent plus one
in the nonpartisan race they just got
elected we now have a new sheriff right
right so we're not using the primaries
for that but even in the partisan races
there was a law passed in 2015 it's sb
499 and it says if only one party
fields candidates in a partisan election
whoever wins in that closed primary is
the candidate
and so we are electing people even in
the closed primary and so what we're
saying is is we think the political
parties are controlling the primary too
much and we want to have more people
being able to participate we want more
candidates to also go forward because
two you know we've got 1.7 million
voters in clark county two people are
actually going to represent that we
don't think so if you want to know more
about the initiative it's a lot to
digest we you can watch the full
interview there on 8newsnow.com
democrats have formed a group called let
nevadan's vote opposing this measure it
calls the changes complicated and
confusing since this is a constitutional
initiative it would have to be approved
by voters this year and then again in
2024 potentially it would take effect in
2026.
next on politics now saving same-sex
marriage the push in congress to put the
right to marry whoever you want into law
and how it follows nevada's example plus
president biden has tested positive for
coronavirus i'll tell you everything we
know about how he's doing i'm hannah
branton washington
countynv.gov
you're watching politics now
a nevada prison warden has resigned two
months after the eight news now i-team
exposed a riot covered up by the
department of corrections william
hutchings stepped down as warden of the
southern desert correctional center up
in indian springs this comes after an
i-team report on a riot there in
december where dozens of inmates took
over an entire unit with prison made
weapons
prison officials downplayed what
happened at the time but now they say
they're investigating
this week president joe biden announced
he has tested positive for coronavirus
he says he's doing well and he only has
mild symptoms hannah brandt is in
washington d.c
the president was supposed to go to
pennsylvania to talk about crime
prevention but on thursday morning he
tested positive for kovitt on two
different tests so instead he's
isolating in the white house i'm doing
well i'm getting a lot of work done i'm
going to continue to get it done and in
the meantime thanks for your concern
just hours after testing positive for
covid president biden tweeted out this
video message he pointed out he is fully
vaccinated and has had two booster shots
his risk of serious illness is
dramatically lower president biden's
doctor says he has a runny nose dry
cough and is feeling a little tired now
he's taking the anti-viral drug paxluvid
which should help reduce the severity of
the disease with highly contagious
variants circulating all over the white
house press secretary says this isn't
surprising at some point everyone's
going to get covet what is important is
to make sure that you have you get the
treatment that is that we have provided
for folks the white house doesn't know
exactly how or where the president
caught the virus but they are working on
identifying his recent close contacts
one of them first lady jill biden tested
negative on thursday i am going to keep
my schedule i am according to cdc
guidelines i'm keeping math as doctors
continue to monitor the president and
his symptoms speaker nancy pelosi says
this is a good reminder none of us is
immune from it including the president
of the united states and we really have
to
be careful dr jaw says the plan is for
the president to stay isolated for at
least five days but when he tests
negative he can resume with his normal
schedule in washington i'm hannah brandt
this week house lawmakers passed a bill
to enshrine same-sex marriage
protections into law same-sex marriage
has been legal since a 2015 federal
court ruling however it is not enshrined
in federal law
republican leadership argued against the
bill they say it's not needed because
same-sex marriage isn't threatened
democrats say they don't want to wait to
find out if it is
justice clarence thomas explicitly
called on the court to reconsider his
decisions protecting other fundamental
rights including the right to same-sex
marriage here's what the court said in
the dobbs decision the dobbs decision
should not be misunderstood
mischaracterized
to cast doubt on precedents that do not
concern abortion
they're both referencing the ruling that
overturned roe v wade where this was
discussed nevada's three democrats all
voted for this measure republican
congressman mark yamade voted against
the respect for marriage act
nevada was the first state to put
same-sex marriage protections in its
constitution it was through a ballot
initiative which passed in 2018 and
2020. the same initiative also says a
member of the clergy who objects to gay
marriage cannot be compelled to perform
them
this week republican senators took a
trip to the southern border and they say
the crisis there is getting worse texas
republican senators ted cruz and john
cornyn say it's just not safe for border
patrol right now and they say the agency
is understaffed compared to the migrants
who are making the journey and it's
dangerous
it's dangerous not only to the migrants
that sometimes become injured or sick
and die
in route to the united states but it
also provides a
channel of illegal drugs i'm from south
texas i don't see an evasion when i go
home i'm not afraid i don't think we're
going to be invaded
democrats say republicans are painting
the wrong picture republican senators
are putting pressure on president biden
to change his border policies and visit
the region himself
supreme court justices denied a bind
administration request to continue with
its immigration informed enforcement
policies as a lawsuit continues the
policy in question sets enforcement
priorities for the border patrol on
people with serious criminal convictions
and recent border crossers texas and
louisiana sued to block it however the
supreme court agreed to take up the case
in december
new curfews in downtown las vegas next
on politics now when the city could vote
on putting a new curfew at the fremont
street experience